in a previous video we talked about
interphase which is the bulk of a cell's
lifecycle as it grows and its DNA
replicates and it grows some more and
now we're going to talk about the actual
cell division we're going to talk about
mitosis and if we wanted to be precise
mitosis is the process by which this one
nucleus will turn into two nuclei that
each have the original genetic
information now as we exit mitosis we
get into cytokinesis which will then
split these two nuclei into or they'll
put each of the nuclei into a separate
cell when we split the cytoplasm right
over here when we split the or or the
the cell essentially turns into two
cells but let's see how all of this
let's see how all of this happens so the
first phase and I'll leave the end of
interphase right over here we have this
big cell our DNA has been our DNA has
been replicated we have two centrosomes
right over here the first phase of of
mitosis involves the cell and I might
draw it a little bit smaller just so I
have enough space here so involved so
this is the cell right over here so
we're going to go to this phase right
over here and a few things start
happening one the DNA the chromosomes go
from being in there chromatin form where
they're all spread out to kind of a more
condensed form that you can actually see
from a light microscope so for example
that magenta chromosome which is now
made up of two sister chromatids after
replication we talked about that in the
interphase video it might look something
like this in a it might look something
like this if you were to look in a in a
microscope it wouldn't it's unlikely to
be magenta but it's going to have kind
of that classic chromosome shape that
you're used to seeing in textbooks and
it has the centromere that connects
these two sister chromatids right now
both of this both of these two sister
chromatids combined are considered to be
one chromosome even though before
replication it was still considered the
magenta stuff was still considered to be
one chromosome and we could draw the
blue chromosome once again it's now in
the condensed form that's one
sister chromatid right over there that's
another sister chromatid they are
connected at the centromere
at the centromere so they're condensing
now as we enter into mitosis and the
nuclear membrane the nuclear membrane
starts to starts to go away so the
nuclear membrane is starting to go away
and these two centrosomes start to
migrate to opposite opposite sides of
the cell so one of them is going over
here and one of them's maybe going to go
over here so they're migrating migrating
to opposite sides of the cell and it's
pretty incredible you know when we it's
easy to say oh this happens and then
that happens but remember this this cell
doesn't have a brain this is all
happening through chemical and
thermodynamic reactions and the ways we
you know just based on certain triggers
of where the cell is in its lifecycle
it's amazing that this is happening it's
amazing that the structures and what
sometimes we consider to be a simple
thing but this is actually incredibly
complex thing is actually it kind of
quote-unquote knows what to do even
though it has no intelligence here and a
lot of what I'm talking about the
general overview of the process is well
understood but scientists are still
understanding exactly how do the
different things happen when they should
happen and by what mechanism and what's
actually happening sometimes in a
molecular or atomic basis but anyway
this first phase of mitosis the nuclear
envelope the nuclear membrane starts to
disappear the centrosomes migrate to the
opposite ends of the cell and our DNA
condenses into kind of the condensed
form of the chromosomes we call this
prophase prophase prophase of mitosis
now in the next phase in the next phase
let me draw my cell again during that
same green color in the next phase your
your cell your nuclear membrane is now
is now gone and the chromosomes start
lining up in the middle of the cells so
you have the blue
one right over here the blue one that's
one sister chromatid here's another
sister chromatid and they are connected
at the centromere not to be confused
with a centrosome and then here's the
magenta one of the magenta sister
chromatids and another one and once
again it's not magenta in real life I'm
just making it in magenta because it's
it looks nice
that's the centromere right over there
our centrosomes our centrosomes are at
opposite ends of the cell at this point
at opposite ends of the cell and you
might have heard the word let me let me
label this again I labeled it in a
previous video that's centrosomes
centrosomes where the two sister
chromatids are connected that's a
centromere centromere now you might have
heard the word centriole centrioles are
actually they help they are exist inside
the centrosomes there are these two kind
of cylindrical looking structures each
of the centrosomes have two centrioles
but for the sake of this video you could
say well the centrioles are just part of
the centrosomes but i'm just listing you
all the words that involve century
something centrioles right over there
and you have two of them per centrosome
so hopefully that that helps clarify
some confusion but these things line up
and a lot of what you're about to see
this orchestration these things moving
around and the cell things lining up and
soon things pulling apart these are all
coordinated with actually a fairly
sophisticated mechanism of kind of a
scaffold of these kind of ropes these
these microtubules and the centrosomes
role until now I've just been kind of
drawing them you're like well what do
they do well the centrosomes role is
these microtubules extend from them to
each other and to the centromeres and to
the centromeres of of these chromosomes
and to a large degree although they're
not the only actors here they help pull
and push things in the right way so
these help keep make sure that the two
centrosomes push away from each other
and then well as we'll see in the next
phase that they're able to pull one of
each of the sister chromatids four from
each of the pairs towards towards
towards each of them so this right over
here where you see where where the
nuclear envelope is now gone the
chromosomes have been lined up just like
this and your centrosomes are on
opposite sides of your opposite sides of
your cell we call this the metaphase we
call this the metaphase of mitosis and
then you can imagine what's going to
happen next what's going to happen next
what's going to happen next is let me I
don't want to draw it too big because I
want to be able to fit it all in one
page what's going to happen next is that
those microtubules are going to start
pulling on each of the sister chromatids
let me draw that so so let me drew so
you have this centrosome right over here
you have all these microtubules in your
cell you have this centrosome right over
here all those microtubules and this one
is going to be is going to be pulling is
going to be getting one of the blue
chromatids to pull towards it or to move
towards it so let me draw that
so this is one blue chromatid right over
here and this one is going to be pulling
the other blue chromatid towards it and
same thing for the magenta and same
thing for the magenta so that one's
being pulled that way and this one is
being pulled that way and just in case
you're concerned about the the some of
some of more of the words the vocabulary
involved the point at which these
microtubules connect to what used to be
sister chromatids but now that they're
part we now call them chromosomes this
is when it were merged this was one
chromosome and they have two sister
chromatids but now they're apart we
would actually now consider these each
and independent chromosome so now you
actually have four chromosomes over here
this point right over here we call a
kinetic or kinetic or even exactly how
that interface works and exactly how
things move is not fully understood some
of this stuff is understood but some of
this is still an area of research so
something even as basic as cell division
not not so basic after all so this right
over here where you can start to see
DNA kind of migrating to their
respective sides of the cell we call
this the anaphase we call this the
anaphase and then that takes us to the
last formal phase of mitosis and that is
called telophase talo
telophase and in telophase in telophase
let me do my best job to draw draw it
and you could already see I've started
to draw that the cells that the the
cellular membrane starting to pinch in
kind of in preparation for cytokinesis
in preparation for the cell splitting
into two cells so I'll do it a little
bit a little bit more cytokinesis is
usually described as kind of being a
separate process than mitosis although
it is obviously they are they kind of
together help the cell fully turn into
two cells so now in telophase so you
have this what used to be a sister
chromatid now we could call it a
chromosome on its own and we have this
chromosome and we have and we have this
chromosome right over there let me
actually do it on both sides so you have
there and you have you have this right
over here and actually let me draw it a
little bit different because at this
phase you're really starting to unwind
what happened at prophase so prophase
you have the disappearance of the
nuclear membrane and you have the
condensation of the chromosomes into
this form here telophase that's that's
unwinding a little bit so actually let
me draw the two centrosomes so you have
one centrosome that same color that i
had before so you have one centrosome
right here you have another centrosome
right over there and now the DNA this
blue DNA this chromosome is now here but
starting to get an unwind a little bit
same thing on this side right over here
magenta chromosome is on here but once
again starting to get a little bit
unwound same thing over here
and you start to have nuclear membranes
forming forming around the DNA so once
again it's kind of its kind of redoing
what was undone in prophase undone in
prophase and so when you're done you
essentially you're going to
these nuclear membranes the DNA is going
to go back to its chromatin form and
then you have cytokinesis and
cytokinesis is the process by which this
gets fully pinched together and you have
two separate cells and some folks will
say oh it kind of begins in anaphase and
you know it finishes after telophase but
it's kind of happening near the end of
mitosis in parallel with it so this is
cytokinesis cytokinesis cytokinesis
right over here this essentially is how
the the this larger cell that had two
nuclei how this divides fully divides
into two into two cells and at that
point you're back to you're back to this
phase of the cell cycle now each of
these now two cells are going to go
through interphase g1 s phase replicate
their DNA g2 phase grow some more and
then go through mitosis again and then
these two will turn into four cells
anyway hopefully you enjoyed that